se cumplen 500 años de la caída del
imperio azteca tras 75 días de sitio el
13 de agosto de 1521 los españoles
guiados por hernán cortez tomaron
brutalmente la capital del imperio
méxico-tenochtitlan la conquista fue
posible por la alianza de los colonos
hispánicos con pueblos indígenas
confrontados a los aztecas los días
previos al aniversario en ciudad de
méxico grupos de defensa de la cultura
prehispánica conmemoraron la resistencia
de sus raíces a través de siglos de
opresión
pues me siento orgullosa porque estamos
a 500 años recordando no la caída
estamos recordando el resurgimiento de
nuestras raíces que son muy profundas
raíces que penetran el zócalo la plaza
principal de ciudad de méxico que fue
levantada sobre el centro político y
religioso de tenochtitlan nuestra
cultura la escribieron los vencedores
entonces esos vencedores dejaron escrito
mediante su pensamiento su palabra
porque está en español
y su idea
entonces está todo alterado tergiversado
distorsionado con el objetivo de
repensar la historia un grupo de
investigadores de la unam desarrolló el
videojuego y aúpan sobre la historia de
los clash caltech as uno de los pueblos
mesoamericanos que participó junto a los
españoles en el derribo del imperio
azteca hay diferentes versiones sobre
esta historia esta es una más la de los
clash caltech así la del pueblo atrás
caltech a que se eligió como vencedor de
los de las guerras y las alianzas de
conquista y así lo expresaba en
documentos como el lienzo de tlaxcala
500 años después documentos como el
lienzo de tlaxcala son un túnel del
tiempo a la colonización española